I told you that I want to go to that
festival in Sweden no when you said it
would be cool to go yeah and then I got
the opportunity and I decided to do it
you going I just wish he would have told
me that's all do it she needs a
therapist you've been wanting out of
this stupid relationship for like a year
now and don't forget about all of the
beautiful Swedish women you'll need in
June okay guys that's not her again
seriously babe what's happening then
I was so very sorry to hear about her
happen I was
I invited Danny to come to Sweden you
know what she's been going Christian
says you've got this special week
planned it's sort of a crazy festival
special ceremonies and dressing up
sounds fun
[Music]
unbelievable welcome at happy midsummer
school what time is it 9:00 p.m. that
can't be right the skies blue this is
what 9 p.m. is like here
how long have you two been together just
over three and a half years four years
really yeah what do you think it's like
another world tomorrow's a big day is it
scary what is it it has special
properties what am I going through
we just need to acclimate I don't want
to acclimate I want to go absolutely not
what is happening
that's why you look so guilty right now
because you know
we only do this every 90 years
I was most excited for you to come
you